er hat ja zu dem zeitpunkt damals noch
ein t3 bus westfalia campingbus in dem
hat er dann über über übernachtet und
ich habe nur angeboten jahr wenn du auf
die toilette muss dann kommt station mir
auf und irgendwann mal hatte dann gesagt
könnte auf dem dachboden schlafen da war
das wetter zeitweise nicht so gut das
hat er dann auch gemacht an dem
dachboden genächtigt hat dann auch meine
räumlichkeiten benutzt wie gesagt
toilette küche essen meine wohnung so
weit so gut aber irgendwann mal habe ich
dann schon gemerkt dass er drogen
vertickt dass er eben haschisch kauft
und verkauft irgendwann mal habe ich
dann gesehen dass er das ding dann
bearbeitet sauber macht und zum trocknen
hat dach wurden haus gelegt hat das hat
dann also sehr aromatisch gerochen
irgendwann noch mal habe ich mir dann
gedacht na ja das ist dann schon ein
bisschen heftig was er da macht